12 "First Times Ever" You Need to Know!
1.
The First Completed Pass ever thrown by Brett
Favre (note to Simon- pronounced “Farv”)
was to himself…
In his first official play in the NFL during
the second game of the 1992 season, Favre
threw the ball only to have a defender deflect
it back.
Favre caught the ball and was tackled for
a loss of 7 yards.
2.
The First Cell Phone weighed 2.4 pounds and
was 9x5x1.75 inches in size.
It also had only 20 minutes of battery life
when talking, but as Motorolla employee Martin
Cooper stated “that wasn’t really a big
problem because you couldn’t hold that phone
up for that long.”
Once the phone battery was drained, it took
approximately 10 hours to charge back up fully.
3.
The First UPC Barcode was a pack of Wrigley’s
Juicy Fruit gum, first scanned in Marsh’s
supermarket in Troy, Ohio in June of 1974.
4.
The First Known Female Doctor was Merit Ptah
who lived in Egypt around 2700 B.C.
According to her son who was a High Priest,
she wasn’t just any doctor, but “the Chief
Physician”.
5.
The First Recognized “Baby Boomer” was
Kathleen Casey-Kirschling of Philadelphia.
She was the first known baby to be born on
January 1, 1946, born in St. Agnes Hospital.
6.
The First Name In “Baskin-Robbins” was
decided by a coin-flip, with Burt Baskin winning
the toss against his brother-in-law, Irv Robbins.
7.
Man First Set Foot On The Moon at the “Sea
of Tranquility”.
The second landing site was called “The
Ocean of Storms”.
8.
The First Punishment that will be leveled
against you if you’re convicted in the Sudan
of armed robbery where you also killed someone
during the robbery (under Article 168 of the
Sudanese Penal Code), is that you will be
hanged.
Next, you will be crucified.
The last such death sentence was carried out
on May 6, 2013.
9.
Famed writer and Soviet spy Whittaker Chambers
was the First To Translate Bambi: A life in
the Woods, into English.
Disney would later, of course, base a movie
off this work.
10.
The First Man To Go Over Niagara Falls in
a barrel and survive, Bobby Leach, 15 years
later died as a result of slipping on either
an orange peel or a banana peel (different
news reports from the event are contradictory
on which).
After the slip and subsequent injury, his
leg became infected and had to be amputated.
He died two months later from complications
from the infection and the surgery.
11.
Nel Blu Dipinto Di Blu, widely known as “Volare,”
was recorded by Italian singer Domenico Modugno,
and was the First Non-English Number One hit
in the history of the prestigious Billboard
Hot 100 chart, when the song climbed to the
top of the American charts on August 18, 1958.
It also ultimately went on to sell over 22
million copies.
12.
The Tower of the Winds in Athens, which lies
right under the Acropolis, is thought to be
the First Clock Tower in history, constructed
sometime between the 2nd century BC to 50
BC.
It contained eight sundials and a water clock,
along with a wind vane.